Okay.
Something strange has been happening in
the remote area of a forest near King's
castle.
Huh?
Every hundred that goes near this area
disappears never to be seen again.
Others are sent to search for
them and they go missing as well.
People begin to believe this
area is cursed and decide
simply never to go there.
A hunter shows up one day and asked the
king if there is any dangerous work that
needs to be done.
The king immediately tells him about
the forest and warns him of the strange
disappearances.
This turns out to be exactly the type
of adventure the hunter was seeking,
so he sets out the young hunter,
wanders with his dog into the
forest until they pass upon.
Suddenly a hand reaches up from the water,
grabs the dog and pause it underneath.
As much as he loved the dog,
the young man doesn't become hysterical.
He simply recognizes that this is
the place he goes back to the castle.
Then rounds up three men and together
they returned to bucket the water out of
the pond.
It is slow and monotonous work,
but they get to the bottom and discover
a large man covered in hair from head to
toe. His hair has reddish like rusty
iron, so they give him the name Iron John.
They take him back to the castle where
he is immediately imprisoned by the king
who then gives the key
into the care of the queen.
When a man looks into his psyche deep
underneath the water in a place no one has
visited for a very long time, he finds
this ancient hairy man line there,
man, as we see him today is a
late, an uncommon phenomenon,
a blip on the radar of human history.
Only recently has there
been a rapid evolution where
all of our animal instincts
have become useless and
in order to survive,
we must now rely on our conscious mind
rather than our unconscious impulses.
If we do actually discover
this wild men exist within us,
what is our first impulse to lock
him up and pretend he isn't there?
Parents,
teachers and ministers and principals
have been telling us our entire life that
we should have nothing to do with him,
that we should be frightened of him.
When he comes out in school,
we medicate him away.
One day the Kings eight year old son is
playing in the courtyard with a golden
ball. He loves, he loses the ball
and it rolls into iron John's cage.
If he wants it back, he must approached
the wild man and ask him for it.
The boy is eight and it is around this
age that all of us boy or girl loses
something of incredible value.
This is the same golden ball in the
princess and the frog that is lost the
bottom of the pond.
It is also the golden ball that Harry
Potter is so desperately trying to catch.
It represents the most
important thing in our lives.
It reminds us of that unity of
personality we had as children.
I kind of radiance or
wholeness we possessed before
the more difficult aspects
of life began to set in.
If we still have the ball in kindergarten,
we lose it in grade school.
If we still have it in grade school,
we lose it in high school and once the
ball is we spend the rest of our lives
trying to get it back. Obviously this
wouldn't be much of a story of iron.
John simply gave the ball back to him.
Instead,
our psyche is a deal maker and we
must be willing to bargain with it.
So Iron John offers the boy a deal.
He will give the ball back if
the boy agrees to open the cage.
The boy gets frightened and runs off, but
he returns to the next day. In reality,
this day that has passed might
be 10 years. On the second day,
the boy can now be 25 he asks,
can I have my ball back?
The wild man says, yes. If
you let me out of my cage,
the boy hears him,
but by now he has two Toyotas or
mortgage and possibly a wife and kids.
How can he possibly let the wild man out?
Now he leaves again without saying
a word and returns the next day.
On this third day, perhaps another
10 years have passed the boys.
Now 35 look into the eyes of a 35
year old man in what do you see?
Men that are overworked, alienated,
and completely beaten down by life.
Again, he asks him, can I have my
ball back? The wild man says, yes.
If you've let me out of my cage this time,
the boy responds.
Even if I wanted to let you out,
I don't know where the key is.
The Wild men tells him the key is
under his mother's pillow. It is here.
The story takes a very Freudian turn
in case you're not familiar with Freud.
In one of his more famous ideas,
the Oedipus complex,
he describes what he thought
of as a universal infant tile,
which we all have to kill our fathers
and sleep with our mothers and vice versa
for father daughter relationships,
something we are still
vehemently suppressing to this
very day and now you know
why? Literally everyone
in the world hates Freud.
While many believe he's mistaken in his
attempt to reduce all general problems
of humanity down to this
kind of repressed sexuality,
he was able to diagnose
a very real problem.
It is the stereotype of the father with
a shotgun at his daughter's wedding or
the 30 year old man living
in his mother's basement.
It is the overbearing and
overprotective tendency.
All parents and especially
mothers feel for their children,
but it is wrong except in extreme
cases to place the blame on the mother.
As many in the 40 in school are prone
to do for where would we all be without
the fierce protection we receive from
our mothers and another time it was the
tribe who decide when to take the boy
away from his mother and guide his
transition into adulthood.
These initiation rights would
be incredibly challenging.
The boy would be left
out in the wilderness,
have his body covered in fire ants or
left somewhere clinging halfway between
life and death.
While you might say there is no place
for this in a civilized society,
the complete absence of initiation along
with the epidemic of the 30 year old
man child we see today might have some
correlation. The message is clear.
At some point there must be a clean
break from the family and a proper
transition into adulthood.
But our most common form of initiation,
today's the Frat,
it is boys initiating boys.
There are few men and even fewer who are
actively guiding the initiation of the
next generation.
So for many the key remains hidden.
No matter what it takes,
he must get the key back and he must
realize that nobody is going to come along
and do it for him.
The keys being held underneath the pillow,
perhaps in our parents' dreams
and expectations for us,
they wanted to raise a doctor or a lawyer
and they definitely did not want to
raise a wild man. The boy agrees to
take the key and free orange and John,
but as he's opening the cage,
he cuts his finger on the rusty lock,
breaking away from the parents, define
their wishes and freeing the wild man.
These things will always cause a wound.
These wounds come in various forms.
It can be dealt in a single blow or it
can be a steady, poisoned drip of shame.
Constantly reminding you how you are not
living up to their standards and many
primitive societies. Outward scarring is
given as a reminder of internal scars.
The important distinction is that the
scarring is not coming from a place of
cruelty but rather from a
place of profound meaning.
There is a reason children were scars
and broken bones as badges of honor.
They are looked at with awe and respect.
Adolescence is a time of
extreme risk and suffering.
Wounds is essential to our growth. Once
we are wounded, we have a few options.
We can take the road of grandiosity.
We tried to rise above it all but like
Peter Pan or ICARUS, we fly too high.
We turn into megalomaniacs
or remain naive children.
We can take the road of
numbness and turn into addicts.
If modern men were a bullfighter,
he would simply let the bolts trample
over his body and then wallow in self pity
and talk about how unavoidable it was
medicating himself with alcohol, drugs,
porn or worst of all memes.
Or we can choose not to forget our wounds
but also not to wallow in self pity.
Instead, we can use them to uncover
the real depths of our potential,
where our wound is.
That is where our genius would be found.
Now that Iron John has set free,
the boy has a few options.
He can stay and take all
the blame for releasing him.
He can soak in pity over his wounded
finger, or you can run away with him.
Of course, we know what the boy will
do just as we know what we all must do.
So once the boy has runaway and
followed Iron John into the wilderness,
what happens next? Well, that
is a story for another day.
Thank you so much for watching,
and if you enjoyed the video,
please subscribe from war.
And of course we'll leave a comment
because I love to hear from you guys.
Thank you.
Sure.